TRAPPED IN MARIUPOL, MOST
WITHOUT FOOD OR WATER.
THESE ARE LIKELY BOTH WAR CRIMES
ACCORDING TO THE INTERNATIONAL
CRIMINAL COURT.
OUR CNN REPORTER REPORT THIS IS
ALL HAUNTINGLY FAMILIAR TO THE
SYRIAN PEOPLE WHO KNOW FIRSTHAND
JUST HOW FAR VLADIMIR PUTIN IS
WILLING TO GO, AND WE WANT TO
WARN YOU, SOME OF THE IMAGES
YOU'RE ABOUT TO SEE ARE QUITE
GRAPHIC.
>> Reporter: RUSSIA'S VICIOUS
WAR ON UKRAINE HAS SHOCKED THE
WORLD, BUT NO ONE SHOULD BE
SURPRISED.
FOR YEARS RUSSIA'S RUTHLESSNESS
PLAY OUT SO OPENLY FOR ALL TO
SEE IN SYRIA WHERE COUNTLESS
CIVILIANS PAID THE PRICE FOR
PUTIN PROPPING UP HIS ALLY.
HE BOASTED ABOUT 300 TYPES OF
WEAPONS, IT'S ALSO WHERE HE
TESTED HIS LIMITS AND THERE
SEEMS TO BE NONE.
THIS WAR HAS NO RULES NUMBER ONE
IS SPARE AND NO PLACE IS SAFE.
RUSSIA'S BOMBED MARKETS,
HOSPITALS, AND SCHOOLS.
THE U.N. CALLS THEM WAR CRIMES
BUT NO ONE FACES JUSTICE.
ITS CRUEL ATTACKS NO-NO BOUNDS.
EVEN THOSE WHO HAVE RUSHED TO
HELP THOSE WHO WERE INJURED WERE
TARGETED.
>> MY COLLEAGUES IN ONE SECOND,
WE WOULD TRY TO RESPOND TO SAVE
OTHERS.
>> Reporter: THEY HELPED.
>> WE ARE FORCED TO LEAVE.
>> Reporter: HIS BELOVED ALEPPO
WAS REDUCED TO RUBBLE.
>> ALEPPO WAS LIKE DOOMSDAY.
I SAW BUILDINGS COLLAPSE ON THE
HEADS OF THE FAMILIES, MEMBERS
OF THE FAMILIES, CHILDREN, BY
USING THE BUNKER BUSTER BOMBS.
THIS IS USED FOR THE MILITARY.
THAT WEAPON WAS USED ON
CIVILIANS TO TARGET THE
CHILDREN.
>> Reporter: IN THE LITTLE
THAT'S LEFT OF REBEL-HELD SYRIA,
THE WHITE HELMETS ARE ON ALERT.
THERE'S A FRA GYRE CEASE-FIRE.
THEY ALSO WANT TO HELP UKRAINE.
THEY KNOW RUSSIA'S PLAYBOOK ALL
TOO WELL.
>> THEY WILL BOMB EVERYTHING AND
THEIR MEDIA WILL SAY WE TARGETED
A PLACE FOR SOLDIERS, WE
TARGETED UKRAINIAN ARMIES.
>> Reporter: SO MANY HERE FEEL
THE PAIN UKRAINIANS ARE GOING
THROUGH, PAIN INFLICTED BY THE
SAME AGGRESSOR WHO SHATTERED TOO
MANY SYRIAN LIVES.
THIS ENGLISH TEACHER WITH HIS
BABY GIRL WE BY HIS SIDE
APPEALED TO THE WORLD TIME AND
TIME AGAIN TO SAVE ALEPPO IN
2016, BUT THE WORLD LOOKED THE
OTHER WAY.
>> I MEAN I DON'T KNOW WHY THE
WORLD IS NOT LEARNING.
I MEAN NOT STOPPING RUSSIA AND
SYRIA HAS AFFECTED UKRAINE.
THEY DO THE SAME IN MANY OTHER
COUNTRIES.
>> Reporter: IT'S BEEN MORE THAN
FIVE YEARS HE WAS FORCED OUT OF
HIS HOME.
LIFE IS NOT THE SAME, HE SAYS,
BUT LIFE DOES GO ON.
RIGHT NOW HE SAYS HE JUST CAN'T
STOP THING OF UKRAINE.
>> NONE CAN UNDERSTAND
UKRAINIANS, NONE CAN.
SYRIANS, NONE CAN UNDERSTAND
THEM MORE THAN SYRIANS.
WE UNDERSTAND THEM MORE.
THIS IS WHY I CANNOT NOWADAYS I
CANNOT TEACH WELL, I CANNOT DO
ANYTHING BECAUSE I'M JUST
FOLLOWING WHAT'S GOING ON IN
UKRAINE.
IN FACT, WHAT'S AFFECTING ME A
LOT IS ALL THE WORLD IS
REPEATING THE SAME MISTAKE.
>> THE MISTAKE OF LETTING PUTIN
GET AWAY WITH IT, ALL THE
IMPUNITY IN SYRIA THAT MAY HAVE
EMBOLDENED HIM TO INVADE
UKRAINE.
MANY FEEL THEIR FATE IS NOW TIED
TO UKRAINE.
IF PUTIN'S NOT STOPPED, THEY
FEAR RUSSIA WILL UNLEASH H